(gentle uplifting music)
- So the past year and a half,
I've really been made aware
of the intimate relationship
between our psychology and our physiology.
It seemed like as we were
locked down physically,
we were also locked down mentally.
As we felt kind of stuck in our own homes
and in our apartments,
we also felt stuck inside our own heads.
We fell into cyclical thinking,
and I think a lot of that has to do
with the fact that there
weren't fresh inputs,
no fresh experiences
being added into our lives
so we didn't have novel ideas.
It was all exacerbated as well by the fact
that the algorithms that we
were likely leaning on heavily
through YouTube and Netflix and Twitter
and all of that learn
what we tend to click on.
So we start to develop
these deep digital grooves
into certain topics of interest,
and you start getting recommended
the same content day in and day out
and you start to wonder,
like, why am I stuck in a rut?
Why am I thinking the same things
that I'm thinking all the time
and how come I can't
get out of this pattern?
When you take a step back from it all,
it all becomes pretty obvious,
but when you're trapped in it,
it's hard to gain the
perspective that you need
to get out of that situation
and into a better one.
And that's another thing
that's really become apparent
about human nature over the past year
is that when we don't have
that exterior influence,
when we don't talk to new people,
when we don't have a sort
of an outside network
and we're just trapped
inside our own heads,
it's almost always a really bad thing
over a long period of time.
This isolation almost
always breeds a pessimism,
negative thought patterns
while it might be good
to be alone sometimes and learn
to be alone with yourself,
too much of that, too much isolation,
almost always corrupts us.
It seems like human
beings operate optimally
when we're working together,
when we're giving each other new ideas,
when we're helping each other out,
when we're carrying a load
and accepting responsibility
to help the group and it's this
putting yourself out there,
this voluntary acceptance
of responsibility
that kind of gives life its meaning.
The existential dread of
existence can be kept at bay
when it feels like you're
contributing to something.
As we play a role in
these sub-communities,
in these sports teams,
in these book clubs,
in these volunteer opportunities,
our life seems bigger and more optimistic,
full of more opportunity.
We're not so trapped inside
our own pessimistic way of thinking.
I feel like this is all because
there's an intimate link
between our psychology
and the physical space
that we take up.
The places we go and the
people we interact with
are extensions of our consciousness.
And through these external influences,
we gain access to new
ideas, new ways of thinking.
And we unlock parts of the brain
that we would not have
access to in solitude.
There's a reason why so many
self-improvement junkies
or gurus or psychologist,
Navy Seals will tell you to
make your bed, clean your room,
organize the physical space around you.
Jocko Willink, Jordan
Peterson, you name it,
these people are all saying
that the physical environment
in which you are a part of
is an extension of yourself.
And following the same train of thought,
I would also say the physical size,
the literal square footage
of your physical surroundings
is sort of the square footage
of your mental surroundings,
of your existential surroundings.
And that feels weird to say,
but I feel like people kind
of know this instinctually,
if you never ever leave your house
and you're just trapped
living the same day over
and over and over again,
then your existence really
starts to feel small.
The literal amount of
things that you influence
on a day-to-day basis is quite small.
Your life can start to
feel very insignificant.
You don't actually make a difference
in the world as much as you would
if you were out there
interacting with more things.
And it's the same reason
why people who travel a lot,
they get back from a year of traveling.
They have so many new
ideas and perspectives
and they're so inspired and full of life.
And that's because by physically
traveling to new places,
they mentally travel
to new places as well.
Their existence seems larger.
And if you don't have the luxury
to travel around everywhere at your whims,
and I know a lot of
people absolutely don't,
this still applies to whatever
town or city you live in.
It applies to the activities
that you say yes or no to.
By actually saying yes to
that salsa dancing class
or that Brazilian jujitsu class
or saying yes to playing
volleyball on the beach
with your brother and his
wife, these things matter.
New experiences open your world up
and make your life feel more significant.
This was all just
basically a long-winded way
of saying, get outside.
Obviously not in a way that
will hurt or endanger anybody,
but you guys are smart
by injecting yourself
into the world around you
instead of hiding away
in a tower like Rapunzel,
you'll actually start
to feel like you have
some autonomy over your own life.
So, good luck and get off YouTube.
But if you're still here,
I would love to take the opportunity
to thank a very unique
sponsor of today's video,
and that is Cuts.
Now Cuts is a clothing
company that I've been wearing
for months and months and months.
I'm actually wearing a
Cuts shirt right now.
I've been wearing a Cuts shirt
in the past like five videos or so,
and they're by far the best fitting,
best made, most breathable
shirts I have ever worn
and Cuts is hooking you guys
up with 15% off your order
if you use my link in
the description below
or use the coupon code Joey at checkout.
So if you guys are looking
forward to injecting yourself
into the world and imposing
your will upon society,
and you wanna look fresh
when you're doing it,
then check out Cuts and buy yourself
the best shirt that you'll ever wear.
And if you liked this video,
make sure you actually hit like,
because when you hit like,
the algorithm says, hey,
this was a pretty cool video
and I'm gonna recommend it
to more people and that helps
them out and helps me out.
So it's a win-win for everybody.
And if you're looking
here consider subscribing,
other than that, thank
you so much for watching
and we'll catch you in the next video.